allez c'est l'heure de découvrir les
résultats de votre baromètre Erwan pour
Public Sénat et la presse régionale ce
mois-ci vous êtes intéressé à l'image de
la nuque et du RN on va maintenir encore
un petit peu le suspense pour voir
lequel des deux remporte la bataille de
l'opinion parce qu'on va commencer avec
vos questions traditionnelles évidemment
question mensuelle d'abord la cote de
popularité de l'exécutif effectivement
ce mois-ci 32% des Français estiment
qu'Emmanuel Macron est un bon Président
de la République c'est un point de plus
que le mois dernier cela reste quand
même 8 points de moins qu'il y a un an
au moment de la réélection d'Emmanuel
Macron et pour avoir un ordre d'idée 32%
d'opinion favorables et bien c'est la
popularité qui avait Emmanuel Macron en
décembre 2018 c'est-à-dire au moment de
la crise des gilets jaunes du côté de la
première ministre Elisabeth borne et
bien 28% des Français estiment
qu'Elizabeth borne est une bonne
première ministre elle reste assez
stable depuis le début de l'année 2023
c'est-à-dire depuis le début de la
réforme des retraites mais c'est quand
même 15 points de moins qu'à son arrivée
l'an dernier à Matignon où elle avait 4
3% d'opinion favorables
Erwan qu'est-ce qu'il faut voir dans
cette sorte de stabilité de l'exécutif
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour Emmanuel
Macron Élisabeth borne alors on est
plutôt quand même sur des Français qui
sont pas réconciliés avec le couple
exécutif ça c'est le point important on
est à un niveau bas de bonnes opinions
Alexandre le rappeler on est très proche
du score plancher d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'Élysée et si on compare avec des
centres 2022 donc avant que ne soit
réamorcé la réforme des retraites on
était à 41% de bonnes opinions donc il y
a encore 9 points qui n'ont pas été
réengés par le Président on est donc à
un niveau bas en revanche il y a deux
petits motifs peut-être de satisfaction
pour Emmanuel Macron c'est que tout
d'abord et ça c'est nos partenaires de
mascaraît qui le relèvent dans l'analyse
des réseaux sociaux aussi parce qu'on a
une actualité politique qui est moins
intense il y a de moins en moins de
commentaires négatifs sur Emmanuel
Macron dans les conversations en ligne
ça c'est un point du côté des plus
virulents ils sont un peu démobilisés et
il y a aussi les soutiens Emmanuel
Macron qui s'élargissent alors très
doucement mais on voit un regain de du
président auprès des cadres auprès des
sympathisants du parti socialiste des
Franciliens donc un électorat plutôt
affinitaire mais auprès duquel voilà son
socle s'élargit ce qui est intéressant
c'est de regarder aussi le point de vue
historique et du coup j'ai regardé les
codes de popularité de chaque Chirac et
d'Alain Juppé après le mouvement social
le 95 est-ce qu'on a observé c'est que
la cote de popularité d'Alain Juppé a
mis plus longtemps à retrouver les
couleurs que celles de Jacques Chirac
qui est revenu plus vite à son niveau
d'avant mouvement social Jacques Chirac
c'est en mai en mars 96 qui retrouve des
bonnes opinions à son niveau d'avant le
mouvement social dans la foulée de
l'annonce des arrêts nucléaires et de la
suppression du service militaire
national alors que pour Alain Juppé ça
s'est passé dans un temps un peu plus
long et on retrouve cette configuration
pour Elizabeth borne aujourd'hui c'est
que comme Alain Juppé c'est une première
ministre dont la grande réforme de début
de mandat a construit l'image et c'est
vrai que ça va être d'autant plus
difficile de dépasser la réforme des
retraites pour Elizabeth borne parce que
sur le fond et sur la forme elle est
extrêmement reliée à cette réforme tous
les retraites donc aujourd'hui 28%
une grande stabilité ça c'est le point
important et donc dans un contexte où de
Français sur trois souhaitent en
remaniement avec changement de Premier
ministre elle est forcément un peu
fragilisée et c'est vrai que retisser un
lien de confiance avec les Français va
prendre probablement plus longtemps que
pour Emmanuel Macron qui lui est aussi
quand même il faut le souligner un
niveau bas c'est à la fragilité dans le
cadre d'un éventuel remaniement clair et
des abattement
effectivement alors on a vu qu'Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé et qu'il temporisait
que il donnait sa confiance à sa
première ministre c'est vrai que c'est
les rumeurs du moment c'est quel
ministre vont être remplacés apparemment
Isabelle borne serait voilà conforté
mais c'est vrai qu'on voit que c'est ces
derniers mois il y a eu un activisme du
gouvernement enfin on ne compte plus les
dizaines de plans qui ont été annoncés
tous a dit mais ça a commencé avec l'eau
sur un sujet un peu plus courant sensuel
on s'en souvient juste après le 49-3
premier déplacements mis en scène dans
les dans les Hautes-Alpes et depuis on a
eu la jeunesse enfin tous les dossiers
que Emmanuel Macron vraiment pointé
fléchés comme c'est priorités on
s'occupe des Français on va parler
environnement santé éducation là on l'a
vu encore hier à Marseille dans le cadre
d'un déplacement il y a la sécurité
enfin voilà donc on voit bien qu'il y a
cette activité mais que finalement bon
ça imprimerait un petit peu mais
peut-être pas autant que le que le
gouvernement le souhaiterait en revanche
effectivement on semblerait que alors
est-ce que les gens ont tourné la page
de retraite où on le verra aussi lors
des prochaines élections est-ce que
voilà est-ce qu'il y a un découragement
un dépit est-ce que voilà où est-ce que
véritablement pour les gens on sait
c'est réglé et on verra en septembre la
mise en oeuvre et comment ça va se
passer mais c'est vrai que dans
l'opinion aujourd'hui voilà l'agenda a
changé mais que malgré tout l'activisme
du gouvernement ne semble pas vraiment
redorer l'image du gouvernement on va
voir la suite de ce baromètre et là
aussi comme tous les mois le palmarès de
l'adhésion palmarès des personnalités
politiques et comme tous les mois c'est
toujours le maire du Havre et l'ancien
Premier ministre édou Philippe qui en
tête et oui c'est toujours Édouard
Philippe 36% des Français ont de la
sympathie pour l'ancien Premier ministre
alors c'est quand même deux points de
moins que le mois dernier sur le podium
il y a marine Le Pen Jordan Bardella le
patron du RN même s'il perdent aussi
quelques points de popularité en
revanche il y en a un qui monte c'est
François Ruffin le député insomnie qui
ne cache plus ses ambitions
présidentielles 20% des Français ont de
la sympathie pour François Ruffin quand
même une hausse de plus trois points et
du côté de la ministre marine chappa et
bien elle perd 4 points de popularité
c'est sans doute du à l'affaire du fond
Marianne sur laquelle enquête les
sénateurs de ce mois-ci sur ce baromètre
des personnalités Erwan c'est qu'on a
deux personnalités qui sont quand même
nettement en tête 10 points devant les
autres en termes de code d'adhésion ça
c'est le point important et finalement
un couple qui rejoue un peu le match de
2017 et 2022 avec Édouard Philippe dans
la peau d'Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le
Pen dans son dans son propre rôle mais
Edouard Philippe très soutenu par les
cadres les Franciliens les Français les
plus aisés les plus âgés et les
sympathisants Renaissance et LR et de
l'autre côté Marine Le Pen soutenu par
une population plus jeune par des
ouvriers par des habitants de communes
périurbaines de zones rurales donc deux
personnalités politiques qui font un peu
système qui sont assez hautes et juste
dans le détail parce que c'est
intéressant c'est à regarder vous parler
de ces deux personnalités alors Édouard
Philippe il a beaucoup de sympathie mais
moins de soutien Marine Le Pen elle
reçoit beaucoup de soutien et moins de
sympathie parce qu'elle a un socle quand
même très forgé par trois candidatures à
l'élection présidentielle donc c'est
assez logique de la retrouver assez haut
Édouard Philippe accroche peu parce que
il sort de son rôle de premier ministre
n'a pas été candidat encore à l'élection
suprême mais c'est ça ne dit rien de la
différence de perception sur cette
différence justement il y a le rejet
aussi Édouard Philippe il y a beaucoup
moins de gens qui rejettent et Édouard
Philippe que Marine Le Pen qui reste
quand même rejeté par quasiment la
moitié des des Français donc l'image
n'est pas tout à fait la même mais voir
Marine Le Pen aussi haut dans le
baromètre alors qu'en général c'est
plutôt des personnalités modérées sans
tristes qui sont en haut de ce type de
baromètre c'est quand même assigner et
ça montre que c'est vraiment placé au
cœur du jeu politique et à gauche donc
vous parliez de François Ruffin c'est
étonnant de voir qu'il progresse on voit
ça aussi pour Fabien Roussel mais
finalement il progresse moins à la
gauche de la gauche qui est quand même
le cœur de leur de leur électorative que
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui reste la
référence 88% de côte d'adhésion pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon auprès des
sympathisants insoumis qui est la
première personnalité de gauche dans le
baromètre voilà absolument mais en
revanche Jean-Luc Mélenchon dès lors
qu'on est chez les sympathisants PS ou
les sympathisants europécologie les
Verts sa cote d'adhésion et inférieure à
50%. mais même chez les composantes de
la nups donc lui il a une image très
clivée mais ça reste quand même la
figure référente de la gauche
ce duel entre Marine Le Pen et
l'ancien Premier ministre et en fait on
sait pas trompé pour sa journée de la
nation la fête de la nation du 1er mai
qui était justement un changement avec
cette fête de l'arc elle était allée sur
cette terre d'Edouard Philippe au Havre
en disant bien que c'était une ville
portuaire ouvrière et que bientôt le RN
s'y implanterait ce qui a eu un petit
clash sur sur les réseaux mais on voit
bien bien que quelque part aujourd'hui
Marine Le Pen s'en prend à Emmanuel
Macron c'est un face à face avec avec le
président et elle sait que pour la
prochaine échéance présidentielle ce
sera un autre candidat que elle joue
elle joue ce clivage en plus Édouard
Philippe et l'homme de la retraite à 67
ans il est allé encore plus loin dans
ses propositions sur la réforme de
retraite et on voit bien que dans cette
opposition assez discrète que le RN a
mis antenne sur la réforme des retraites
c'était le point vraiment qu'elle a
qu'elle a mis en avant donc donc c'est
assez intéressant et effectivement on
voit que ça ça continue que Jordan
Bardella sont sur lieutenant était un
bon choix stratégique puisqu'on voit que
sondage après sondage il reste quand
même vraiment haut placé dans les
sondages et celle qui perd le plus Erwan
c'est Marlène Chapa ce mois-ci oui
absolument l'affaire du fond Marianne
assez peu servi son soutien dans dans
l'opinion donc elle baisse énormément
après pour Marlène Schiappa il y a une
petite différence aussi dans le
gouvernement actuel c'est qu'elle est
peut-être sur un secrétariat d'État ou
un ministère qui est moins identifié par
les Français l'économie sociale et
solidaire les questions relatives à la
famille ou au droit des femmes ou à la
citoyenneté par le passé pouvait
probablement créer un lien plus direct
avec les Français là elle est peut-être
une action moins identifiée plus une
affaire négative dans un sondage qu'on a
mené il y a quelques semaines on voyait
que 57% des Français souhaitaient
qu'elle quittent le gouvernement en cas
de remaniement c'était celle qui
arrivait le plus haut dans le souhait de
départ chez les Français alors on va
passer au coeur de ce baromètre l'image
comparée de la nuque et du rassemblement
national et on va commencer à l'ex par
l'image de l'anus c'est union de la
gauche récolte 31% d'opinion favorables
et ce qui est intéressant c'est de
regarder dans le détail comment les
Français perçoivent cette alliance des
parties de gauche autour de la France
insoumise et bien 56% d'entre eux
estiment que la nuque peut amener le
désordre 52% pense qu'elle est
communautariste 48% pense que la nuit
est une menace pour notre démocratie et
puis est-ce que du point de vue
économique la nuque peut apporter à la
France et bien 53% des Français assurent
que le programme de la nuque est
dangereux pour l'économie française 41%
estiment qu'elles défend bien les
classes populaires et seulement 33%
pense que la nuque sort renforcée de son
attitude pendant la réforme des
retraites c'est une image très dure pour
la nuit oui finalement on pourrait dire
au vu de ces résultats qu'après un an de
nouvelles législatures la nuque n'a pas
transformé l'essai de la crédibilité
politique on voit que une popularité en
reflux extrêmement
à la baisse par l'image de la France
insoumise qui pèse beaucoup parce que
cette image communautarise d'extrême
gauche on la mesure beaucoup plus de la
France insoumise que Europe Écologie Les
Verts ou le parti la France insoumise
est-ce que c'est ce qui explique aussi
les réponses à ce baromètre ou pas dans
la structure d'image on voit que c'est
extrêmement pondéré par l'image de la
France insoumise par exemple on voit que
la nuque est beaucoup plus soutenue par
les plus jeunes que par les plus âgés
c'est le cas de la France insoumise ce
n'est pas le cas du Parti social il ce
qui est un électorat plutôt plutôt agi
donc il y a ce point et sur l'image de
de la nuit pour voit bien que alors que
après avec autour de 150 députés élus
sous les couleurs de la nuque en juin
2022 ils arrivaient en position de force
pour être le premier opposant à Emmanuel
Macron finalement ils ont été desservis
par leur année de de législature qui
s'est probablement passé en deux temps
parce que il y a eu à la fin de l'année
2022 l'affaire cadenas il y a eu
certaines déclarations de Fabien Roussel
de Sandrine Rousseau il y a eu des
Bizzbee
la partie socialiste il y a eu l'affaire
Bayou il y a eu quand même tout un
ensemble de choses qui ont montré un
espèce de déséquilibre interne et
aujourd'hui 28% uniquement des Français
disent que la Nupe est une coalition
unie sont deux fois plus ils sont une
fois et demi plus ça le considérait pour
le rassemblement national donc l'unité
est plutôt du côté du rassemblement
national la désunion a quand même marqué
les esprits du côté de la nuque et puis
il y a eu la séquence de la réforme des
retraites où l'indicible et
l'inexmplarité à l'Assemblée nationale
ont été très décrié par les Français
vous êtes très critique à l'égard de
l'attitude des députés de la Nupe à
l'Assemblée nationale et aujourd'hui
voilà 33% uniquement des Français disent
que la nuque sont renforcés de son
attitude durant la réforme des retraites
ils sont 53% à souligner la qualité de
l'attitude du rassemblement national
donc un deux poids de mesure sur ce côté
là qui explique pourquoi l'URL peut-être
et aujourd'hui plus en position de force
et a su s'affirmer comme un opposant à
Emmanuel Macron là où avec la nuque on a
quand même beaucoup le sentiment de
tumulte environnement et on va le voir
claire est-ce que la nuit va à raté sa
première année de législature quand on
va se baromètre je trouve qu'il y a des
indicateurs qui sont particulièrement
cruels notamment dans cet effet miroir
avec le RN notamment sur la capacité à
défendre les classes populaires ou bien
assurer de meilleures conditions pour
les Français qui était quand même des
marqueurs de gauche et de son
positionnement où il arrive d'où le bien
loin derrière le RN et donc on le voit
ça se recoupe avec le vote des classes
populaires ouvrières qui aujourd'hui
aurait tendance à davantage identifier
finalement un parti d'extrême droite
comme comme des soutiens alors notamment
sur une thématique comme le pouvoir
d'achat qu'on a vu s'imposer dans le
dans le débat public ou même sur les
retraites alors qu'il est vrai que
la nuit pêche n'a pas du tout enfin elle
a été extrêmement active peut-être même
trop comme me disait peut-être virulente
dans son style alors que que le RN a une
attitude beaucoup plus discrète on
reviendra peut-être dessus sur cette
différence de style mais c'est vrai que
pour le coup il y a sans doute et je
crois que ça c'est un point de division
au sein de notamment des LFI sur la
stratégie à mener plus tard pour
engranger des bénéfices alors que ils
ont été à la pointe de la mobilisation
sociale et pour rebondir sur ce vous
dites claire on va voir l'image du
rassemblement national dernière partie
de ce baromètre elle est plus favorable
pour la nuque effectivement le
rassemblement national est plus
populaire que la nuque il récolte il
récolte 40% de bonnes opinions dans ce
baromètre quand on regarde l'évolution
de cette opinion vis-à-vis du Front
national puis du RN et bien on constate
qu'elle est de plus en plus favorable au
fil des années avec une progression qui
est vraiment constante dans le détail ce
mois-ci et bien 57 % des Français
estiment que le RN est un parti
d'extrême droite 51% pense que c'est un
parti raciste on peut noter également
que 48% des personnes interrogées voient
ce parti comme une menace pour la
démocratie c'est le même score que pour
la nuque et puis du point de vue
économique 49% pense que le programme
économique du RN est dangereux pour la
France à 53% des Français pensent que le
RN sort renforcé de son attitude pendant
la réforme des retraites c'est
effectivement nettement supérieur à
l'opinion sur ce point vis-à-vis de la
nuque et puis à 46% des Français
estiment que ce parti l'URN défend bien
les classes populaires on va revenir en
détail sur tout ça parce que il y a
beaucoup de choses on commence peut-être
par les bonnes opinions 40%, est-ce que
c'est un bon score Erwan ou pas oui pour
deux raisons la première c'est en
évolution quand on voit qu'on était à 12
% en mars 2011 on voit que la présidence
de Marine Le Pen parce qu'elle arrive en
2011 donc la stratégie de normalisation
de banalisation à réellement fonctionné
et ce qu'on voit c'est quand même et
puis on a même peut-être au-delà
aujourd'hui de la stratégie de
normalisation on est dans la stratégie
de notabilisation et finalement l'image
non seulement c'est banalisée dans le
jeu politique mais en plus c'est
enjoliver ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que finalement on
mesurait déjà 40% de bonnes opinions à
l'égard du rassemblement national il y a
un an toujours 40% cette année et en
fait cette stagnation est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'en général on
avait tendance à observer dans les
sondages d'opinion que quand le RN
engrangeait des succès électoraux et
tendance à faire remonter la
mobilisation contre rassemblement
national et que du coup son image
redescendait aussi vite qu'elle avait
progressé là on voit que cette bonne
image s'installe dans la durée et c'est
un point assez intéressant à souligner
finalement de voir que le rassemblement
national a réussi à s'imposer tout en
étant aux responsabilités comme un
opposant crédible dans l'attitude et
plutôt salué même si vous le montrez il
y a des qualificatifs très négatifs ça
reste un mouvement d'extrême droite et
raciste pour une partie de la population
mais en comparatif avec la nuque l'essai
a l'air plus transformé en termes de
crédibilité du point de vue de
l'attitude et du point de vue de l'unité
une large partie des Français ont
considéré que c'est un parti uni et on
voit effectivement il y a des points
positifs des points négatifs pour le RN
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a plus de points
positifs que pour la nuque claire oui
surtout les items à une dizaine d'items
que vous mesurez on voit qu'ils ont
progressé alors que au global notamment
sur les opinions on voit que la nuit
pêche a chuté de 5 points sur un an donc
on a une stabilisation qui comme vous le
disiez et quelque part une victoire
puisque d'habitude il y avait un effet
voilà bah clash quand il y avait une
victoire électorale alors que manifeste
elle n'a pas réussi à véritablement
transformer l'essai et c'est vrai que
sur cette attitude on a parlé de la
stratégie de la cravate donc pas de
notabilisation de Sébastien Chenu
indévis président ARN de l'Assemblée
disait que les féminin a joué aussi
parce que de l'autre côté
eux ils essayaient de
s'institutionnaliser alors que de
l'autre côté la nuit passe elle voulait
porter la colère sociale la colère du
pays dans les institutions donc oui ces
humeurs cette conflictualité qu'ils
essayaient d'injecter on voit
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'opinion ça ne
prend pas c'est que ce soit la violence
dans la rue la violence à l'Assemblée ça
a plutôt tendance à venir dramatiser un
sécuriser les gens et on voit bien que
la stratégie qui a mis en place le RN
qui finalement a continué cette comment
dire opposition constructive qu'ils
avaient mis en place dans les exécutifs
régionaux c'est-à-dire voter pour des
projets des majorités même si c'était
pas parfait mais si ça allait dans le
bon sens donc on montre qu'on ne
s'oppose pas on ne bloque pas mais on
fait avancer certaines choses et
d'ailleurs sur le grand nombre de
projets portée par la majorité que ce
soit le pouvoir d'achat les lois de
programmation des Français intérieures
justice enfin militaire enfin il y a
énormément pardon excusez-moi sur
lesquels ils ont voté et par ailleurs
sur les retraites moi sur le censure ils
ont mis en scène sur le dossier le plus
médiatique une opposition et quelque
part ça a imprimé c'est à dire qu'ils
ont donné l'idée et c'est vraiment le
tout l'enjeu pour Marine Le Pen de
devenir un parti de gouvernement alors
est-ce qu'ils ont réussi à montrer
qu'ils ont une expertise des figures
médiatiques ça je pense qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de voilà de travail sur sur
beaucoup de points mais en tout cas on
voit bien dans ce sondage que l'effet
miroir a été a été amplifiée par ce ça
va être cette change sur cette stratégie
totalement différente d'opposition et on
va le voir justement cet effet miroir
puisque vous avez aussi superposé les
deux images comparées on va regarder ça
et c'est vrai que là où les cas est le
plus important entre le rassemblement
national et la Nupe c'est sur l'attitude
durant la réforme des retraites oui et
c'est vrai que c'est c'est ce que disait
claire c'est vraiment cette différence
entre une stratégie d'interpellation
d'un une stratégie de notabilisation de
l'autre qui crée quand même une
différence de perception des Français
dans un contexte où les députés ont déjà
une image négative dans la population
qui a perdu encore cette année dans le
baromètre de la confiance politique donc
les députés avaient déjà une image
écornée il y a eu les affaires de
violences sexistes et sexuelles en fin
d'année dernière donc peut-être que dans
ce temps parlementaire ou les Français
nous avaient dit d'ailleurs au moment où
il y a une majorité relative seulement à
l'Assemblée pour la majorité
présidentielle on souhaite une
opposition constructive et c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas retrouvé cette opposition
constructive dans l'attitude de la nuque
et c'est sûrement ça qui les a desservis
et c'est pas forcément sur ce type de
prise de position qu'ils étaient
attendus on va regarder l'infographie si
on peut juste la mettre de cette image
comparée puisque du coup les chiffres
sont assez éloquents sur la latitude
l'écart sur l'attitude durant la réforme
des retraites c'est approuvé par 33% du
côté de la nuque et par 53% du côté du
rassemblement national et on le voit
dans l'écart c'est ce qu'on disait
Erwan c'est là où c'est le plus
important entre les deux oui tout à fait
il y a une différence aussi importante
sur la capacité à assurer des meilleures
conditions de vie aux Français à
proposer des solutions concrètes pour le
pays à proposer des idées dont les gens
se sentent proches bien un lien avec les
Français et la capacité à générer des
bénéfices pour la vie quotidienne du
français lambda qui est plus important
quand on parle du RN que quand on parle
de la nuque pour autant faut bien
préciser qu'on reste sur des bas niveau
c'est pas des parties qui font
l'unanimité ni l'un ni l'autre mais la
capacité à comprendre les besoins des
Français et plus créditer aujourd'hui
côté ARN le côté Nupe et il y a aussi un
autre point clair vous en parliez tout à
l'heure c'est sur la défense des classes
populaires puisque les deux se disent en
première ligne sur la défense des
classes populaires et là aussi c'est le
rassemblement national qui remporte le
match mais ça c'est un point vraiment
vraiment intéressant on dirait qu'ils
ont emporté à la fois sur l'ordre et la
colère sociale en fait ils ont ils ont
gagné sur les deux
Marine Le Pen pendant son discours à la
fête de la nation c'est un espèce de
dénoncer le désordre mais en place par
Emmanuel Macron appelé à la copain n'a
pas utilisé le mot Concorde celui du
président marocain qui est qui est un
apaisement dans le pays cette posture en
fait
imprime et c'est vrai que c'est
paradoxal il faudrait peut-être creuser
même là-dessus parce que quand on
regarde le programme les mesures qui
sont proposées par la coalition de
gauche ils sont beaucoup plus engagés
quelque part si on va sur beaucoup de
points qui sont au cœur des des comment
dire des préoccupations voilà des des
classes populaires mais malgré tout ça
ça imprime beaucoup moins et donc
peut-être que dans ce contexte voilà de
de sentiment d'insécurité ou tout ces
thématiques aussi fortement portées par
le par le RN imprime dans l'opinion
publique immigration voilà justice
peut-être qu'il y a cette ça vient
contrebalancer mais c'est c'est vraiment
intéressant de voir ça il y a un vrai
enjeu de communication et on parlait
tout à l'heure de François Ruffin qui a
qui a un peu progressé dans le baromètre
et il fait partie de ceux aussi un
éléphant qui qui est très lu
intéressant c'est quand même un parti
positionné traditionnellement à
l'extrême droite alors que la nuque à
l'intérieur dans ses composantes il y a
Europe Écologie Les Verts il y a le
Parti social ce qui sont des partis qui
étaient aux responsabilités nationales à
l'exécutif il y a encore 6 ans donc
c'est il y a quand même une différence
de de positionnement dans le paysage
politique qui provoque un certain
étonnement quand on regarde aujourd'hui
que les Français les renvoient dos à dos
avec d'une part l'extrême droite et de
l'autre côté l'extrême gauche ça
explique aussi peut-être la
désactivation du du Front républicain
quand le rassemblement national est
opposé à d'autres candidats mais en tout
cas voilà voir que les ils sont renvoyés
à dos sur le côté extrême c'est
important et autant la nuque est jugée
communautariste autant le rassemblement
national est jugé raciste en tout cas
voilà ce sont pas des qualificatifs qui
plaisent aux Français sont deux parties
qui quand même ont plutôt tendance à
inquiéter l'opinion merci à tous les
deux vrai c'est avec nous on regarde ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux avec Alex
[Musique]
et Alex on commence par cette question
la Une de La Dépêche du Midi Vladimir
Poutine peut-il reprendre la main après
la rébellion du groupe Wagner le coup de
force de
ses hommes de sa ministre privée on se
met le trouble sur la réalité du pouvoir
du président russe est-il encore le
maître incontesté de l'État russe en
tout cas 4 questions se posent après
cette rébellion avortée que va devenir
Prigogine qui s'est exprimé hier dans un
message audio mais qui est toujours et
bien qui n'est toujours pas localisable
et quelles conséquence pour l'état-major
russe qui a été affaibli par cette
opération et puis qu'elle sort va être
réservée au 25000 hommes revendiqués par
le groupe Wagner alors que Vladimir
Poutine leur a proposé de s'engager dans
l'armée russe
Emmanuel Macron est à Marseille et oui
c'était la Une de La Marseillaise et de
la Provence le président de la
République pour son long déplacement de
trois jours à Marseille a d'abord
rencontré le maire socialiste de la
ville Benoît Payan avant d'annoncer et
bien des mesures sur la sécurité des
renforts pour les forces de l'ordre
après les noms bleus les nombreux
réglement de compte ces derniers mois
dans la cité phocéenne il y aura une
compagnie de CRS supplémentaire à
l'automne 25 nouveaux enquêteurs et puis
une cellule interne ministérielle va
être créée pour lutter contre les
Cahiers de la drogue deuxième journée
aujourd'hui de son déplacement à
Marseille consacré à l'école alors
qu'Emmanuel Macron a déjà annoncé que
dans les quartiers prioritaires et bien
les collèges seront ouverts de 8h à 18h
l'un des journaux du groupe hébra le
handicap et les galères du quotidien et
oui pour beaucoup de personnes en
situation de handicap et bien la vie est
encore trop semée d'embûches face aux
problèmes d'adaptation des logements de
l'architecture urbaine et des commerces
inadaptés et aujourd'hui dans les
colonnes de l'Est Républicain et bien
Julie handicapé de naissance et qui se
déplace en fauteuil électrique à
souhaiter témoigner sur tous ces
problèmes du quotidien et notamment les
trottoirs dans les Russes un véritable
casse-tête pour ces personnes on finit
par le mammouth superstar effectivement
on l'appelle le géant du Gard il s'agit
de l'énorme squelette de mammouth vieux
d'un virgule deux millions d'années et
découvert dans le Gard à Durfort il y a
plus de 150 ans et bien il fait son
retour au Muséum d'histoire naturelle à
Paris après un an de travaux de
restauration et ce n'était pas une mince
affaire à ces travaux de restauration
puisqu'il a fallu et bien numéroter les
200 eaux du spécimen les dépoussiérer et
les consolider
c'est bon c'est pas facile c'est-à-dire
dans le Midi Libre c'est à dire merci
beaucoup Alex on regarde deux une du
groupe Evra l'Alsace et le République à
Laurent sur le casse-tête du logement
étudiant clair c'est-à-dire on a
consacré notre dossier parce que voilà
parcoursup les attributions et voilà des
jeunes qui vont de plus en plus dans
plein de zones du pays et qui galèrent
comme toujours trouver un logement c'est
à dire merci beaucoup claire plancha et
merci beaucoup
Erwan pour voir où on va voir cette
émission c'est sur public sénat.fr à 18h
Thomas Hugues sens public et nous on se
retrouve demain très bonne journée
[Musique]